guess what i found out about myself go
ahead brother
okay so i'm allergic to shellfish and
avocado
okay i've had avocado in like
i don't know years all right probably 10
years no guacamole
yeah yeah nothing i don't like i don't
know yeah it's a shame gotta got a
burrito yesterday from
tacos to madre yeah i don't know
don't say it like that but yeah okay
yeah
anyways i'm sitting here eating this
burrito it's so damn good
right you get into the middle of it
that's the best part guacamole
[ __ ] it what you did yeah what you
finished that [ __ ] i was too hungry
i didn't even say [ __ ] to nobody because
i was like because all my friends know
that if i [ __ ] eat they'll they're
gonna freak out or whatever and like i'm
like bro this is too [ __ ] was there
an epipen anywhere
no dude here's the thing i was fine yeah
you [ __ ]
what what been a [ __ ] about guacamole
no i haven't bro i'm telling you i used
to get so [ __ ] up from it and now
you're good
yeah i'll grow it down that's what i'm
thinking how we go shrimp because you
can do that
your body's ready to go oh no no you
outgrew all this [ __ ] yeah but wait
all right maybe we could do some some
crab in texas i don't know i don't know
but like maybe just try once what does
it say
after the show eighty percent of people
with egg know about eight percent people
with egg milk wheat allergies outgrow
them usually by age sixteen
about twenty twenty five percent
children with peniles you outgrow them
eighty percent who outgrow them will do
so by age
eight algaes to tree nuts fish and
shellfish may be tougher to outgrow
and are often lifelong often well we'll
see
wait wait wait we got shows to do we'll
see we got show we got shows we're
talking about
all right so first okay but that's w i
grew up yeah dude i didn't freak out
another
and i i was like and i wasn't gonna stop
the burrito was [ __ ]
it's worth dying for huh oh yeah yeah oh
yeah [ __ ] it
hold up you know what i need to do i
need to open up a [ __ ]
wing shop because my girl got an air
fryer
congratulations bro congratulations yes
i do dude [ __ ] a conventional oven
[ __ ] a microwave for this air fryer this
alien
magic that cooks your food now really
yeah dude yeah
the way everybody's been talking about
you know how you get like uh
you know how you get like extra crispy
wings from wingstop and they're not that
crispy dude
these wings from the airfryer my girl
does a lemon pepper sauce on it
and right here no wet a wet she does a
wet lemon pepper sauce
so she seasons it puts lemon pepper on
it puts in the deep fryer
halfway through takes it out lathers it
up with my mouth as one
lathers it up with lemon pepper sauce
then once they crisp
with the golden crisp and there's no oil
or nothing it's healthy
then once the it's out then she douses
in the hot sauce
oh are you serious your mouth is
watering
my girl don't do the air fryer with the
barbecue damn now i want some wings
they better have something to do my girl
was watching the tutorials on youtube on
how to cook the wings stuff so she made
her own uh
lemon pepper sauce i was like we need we
need to take this time i hear what i
hate i hear
that's what people do now they just cook
everything in an air fryer dude
like uh chicken strips like healthy uh
like chicken tenders
that's what i was gonna say i heard it's
not it's really good there's no grease
no it's way healthier cleaning it out is
tough i hate cleaning oh not ours
wait what do you mean it's just trays
yeah what kind of you guys you got off
brand dawg no
no you got the off-brand she bought it i
said i got an ear briar
like wow
we'll never use oven again nothing
because uh how much tiger always
might invest uh chicken tenders so we'd
have to heat up the oven get
now dude about six minutes they cook
fast too
and then here's the best part pizza
chicken wings or
steak all in there yeah when you want to
reheat it it makes it crispy it's not
soggy like a microwave and you don't
need to like put oil or anything on it
it's magic
we got the sleeve what have i been doing
i got the 99
the hundred dollar one well this one bro
what the hell is
what you pay for it what the [ __ ] did
you buy
airfryer is the new it's lit it's lit
yeah air fryer is like the new jersey
it's like the thing that's in um
wait i don't see my oh you know i i
think i have
mine's more like that one no you just
went on that the that one this one
that's what i have no yours was
different yeah yours was like a little
box and even ours isn't that when ours
has like three levels to it and then you
just pull the tray
it's easy you see the trailer you got to
clean that out at the bottom no it's
super easy
yeah that yeah you don't have that one
mallet when we get back from texas
i'll tell my girl make those wings oh
come on she does barbecue
lemon pepper and hot are you serious
game changer and then she and then she
so she made them they looked
fire like damn those look pretty good
and she was like well i just want to do
a test for everyone comes over the
conner fight so i think you're like
thursday or friday night she made him
we sat down to watch love island oh i
missed half the episode just
just deep sodium these hot wings to him
you deep throat
yeah that's the name of your restaurant
hey do you get all the stuff off the
wing
no i don't know listen there's too many
wings what am i doing yeah right what
are you doing i can't do the whole
[ __ ] that's some asian [ __ ] they
they're all the bones [ __ ]
you like eat the tenderness you're
talking about the meat or are you
talking about like eating the cartilages
the carbohydrates
i don't eat the cartilage but i can see
how some people join it's the cartilage
you feel like yeah it's like loud
it's disgusting i mean you know there's
more wings some people like the two
where's the bone left oh yeah i can't do
that
some people even eat the bones don't eat
the bowl yeah
if i'm in crab legs and little crab legs
give me problems see them right
i'm on
i know your asians appreciate food
because when i'm my best friend she's
asian and she'll clap every time
your best friend what's her last name
florence oh okay i'm not very excited
the last name tim floyd she's super age
well not that asian alex
[ __ ] you talking about florida i'm
talking about like florence
laura morris something nah she's single
ah she's not asian
is she filipino yes wait is she filipino
though because filipinos tend to have
like spanish last names
you don't even know your best friend
like that you don't know what type she
is she's from santiago
so uh santiago yeah san diego did you
hear how you just said that she is not
very asian
yeah she is okay she claps from the food
yeah instagram
is that asian or not when they clap on
the food that's more of like a racist
thing hollywood used to
dude well no she does it so i know it's
not hold on before i get it
put up instagram for your instagram
what's your best friend do
you know you're working out she's about
she's a worker it's a workout
f-l or yeah uh mate no it's may
m-a-f-l-o-r may yeah m-a-e she ain't
asian i mean no
last name florence first name yeah super
yeah oh she had an underscore yeah okay
go to your page
no no here it is right underscore fl
[Music]
look how asian she is she's asian thank
you i'm not lying i'm not lying
she reversed it i knew my best friend
y'all best friends bro yes so you may
tell me she's your best friend
yeah i met her through comedy 2021 smile
more laugh more dance more sing
more have fun enjoy life that's not some
asian [ __ ]
yeah and literally she sucks that she
eat the bone
yeah all right yeah i got yeah we got
two mini wings dog
yeah yeah yeah what are you trying to do
if
i'm on the 20 wings yeah what's she
doing right there with this right here
which one talk about this one it's a
little darker though yeah
okay we ain't got to do all that all
right
wait what was the quote what was the
quote on that one yeah yeah come on now
let's go okay go to the quote
where you going i don't know nothing
more rare nor more beautiful than a
woman being on
unapologetically unapologetically
herself comfortable and giving myself
more luck
you know she's struggling i'd reach out
to your friend yeah this is totally
that's a good that's what these quotes
are
yeah pour into your cup and fill it up
before you fill anywhere else is up
hashtag love yourself you need to reach
out to her yeah she's okay
you gotta reach out to me still bro yeah
you're right this is that's
crying come on now she did all that
i'm a fan buddy yeah she's crying for
help yeah
she seems like a great person she is but
she crying for help listen
end of story get her an air fryer dog
get her an air fryer
so she can see no i don't have one
i've only eaten food that other people
have made me from there unreal do you
have one chin
no but i just talked to my girlfriend
about this her family bought one and
they didn't like it
they didn't have the experience you guys
had what do you mean they said it wasn't
good they didn't cook
they don't know what the [ __ ] they're
doing probably unreal what brand would
you recommend
cruising let me ask joe what brand arms
is okay cause there's a few like ninja
makes one
cuisinart i wish i was shopping oh yeah
i have a little one big one i want to
put
one in there yeah ninja one i hear is
big turkeys in there
you can put a turkey in there no i want
to get one that fits i think some people
have made like small roasted chickens in
there yeah
i'm never conventional oven no way never
again never you look at it yeah
at air fryer ultimately i just hate
cleaning yeah you guys
messing with dvds i got streaming
[Laughter]
when i get off stage at the lab factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what just run a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son